okay so I have a quote here --sykes film
death factory became its distributors
all-time top grossing title and was also
later sequel eyes how much money is that
six figures seven figures I will I will
never know the answer to that question
because I'm not privy to that type of
thing when we made death factory it was
we could work for hire situation and for
this distributor who had distributed
movies that I directed prior to that and
done well with and he started his own
company called brain damage films and
death factor is one of their first
movies that they paid for like they
basically would this is what
distributors were doing back then a lot
of especially smaller companies they
were doing well enough that they would
produce their own product they were
produced their own films that they could
own outright and then they would you
know use their distribution you know arm
to get them into the stores and stuff so
that's what death factory was and I felt
like it was gonna be a good movie and we
made it but then it turned out to not
only turn out pretty well but it also
was very successful agonda blockbuster
was my first movie in blockbuster was
you know that was really cool to to see
it and it got some good reviews too was
well-received you know in the horror
community and that was pretty much the
end of that I mean I keep hearing from
people about it and it was released all
over the world too I mean I've got
I mean death vectors released in the UK
Germany Poland the you know Russia
France everywhere I mean pretty much
every country you can think of you know
and they did do a sequel but I was not
involved in the sequel I don't know how
much you want to hear about that but I
can tell you things if you want to hear
him it was actually I did I I knew was
the best-selling title because that was
in a magazine that quote was in a
magazine I saw an interview with the
distributor and he said this death
factor is our best-selling title and
then a few years after that I was at a
film market and in Santa Monica and I
was they had with all those rooms they
take over and and I went up to the room
kind of doing my rounds at the time and
I went in the room brain damages room
I'm talking to the president and I'm
looking around the room and I and I just
made it what we call play Gers which is
a pretty big movie bigger than anything
they've ever done and they probably
weren't thrilled with me because I
hadn't given it to them to distribute
but I'm looking around the room and I
see a poster for a death factory sequel
death factory bloodletting it was called
and I was like hey I see you made a
sequel to death factory you know great
that's that's good to know and basically
what happened with that was there was a
guy over there at the company who was a
very power hungry younger guy who
they're gonna make that sequel but he
didn't want anybody who was involved
with the first one involved with that
why would you want them right there just
the people that made the movie that made
you all the money so they made the movie
there they're in Arizona they made the
movie there with people that were local
they didn't bring anybody from LA on to
that and they never asked me even if I
wanted to even contribute like to the
screenplay
and I had to fight to even get my credit
on there as the story you know
characters based on characters created
by which is a standard credit you see on
any sequel or you know any Indiana Jones
movie or whatever you know that's been
franchised out I had to fight for that
credit and they kind of gave it to me
kind of they gave me like a reduced
version of that if you can imagine that
so and that and that one didn't do as
well as the first one it came out but it
was like an on it was like most like a
non-event and you know so that's the
kind of thing that can happen in this
business sometimes when you make a
successful movie you most people would
automatically assume that you would be
brought on to the sequel or they would
launch you on the sequel or something
like that but in that case it was
because of the power dynamics that were
going on behind the scenes that me
neither me nor the producer of the
original death factory were were
involved and if you hadn't have gone to
that film market and been up there
making around you may have never
discovered that I would discover he was
some somebody would have told me some
fan or somebody would have told me or I
would have maybe seen the movie for sale
somewhere or something like that but it
was weird when it came out because that
sequel they didn't release it themselves
or so that was weird because they were a
distributor they gave it to somebody
else and then it it just didn't go
anywhere which I was like well you know
what it's fine with me I mean you know I
wasn't really seeing the cheering
section for that project all it did was
just prove that I made another movie
that did well enough that was sequence
its sequel eyes cam blood was one that
factorize another one and you know now
we've got sequel to hi-8 also so you
know it gives you some kind of makes you
feel like you you have your you're
aligned on something creatively speaking
to be able to come up with some concepts
that are popular enough to you know to
have people want to sequel eyes them and
and you know because that doesn't happen
with every movie obviously is that
something going forward when you have
things put in contracts that if they
decide to make a sequel then they you
have to somehow either be credited
involved because was that something you
didn't think was ever gonna happen I
well you know it's funny when when we
made death factory I'd already done of a
sequel to Camp blood so obviously I was
already in that you know I'd already had
things equalized but you know it's one
of those things where the contracts
bagged them were such like short form
things and there was always that looming
threat of if you don't want to do this
someone else can do it
you know and believe it they won't
didn't mind telling you that you know so
when I made the movie but that I didn't
think it would there would be a sequel
to death factory but then again I didn't
think there'd be a sequel to Camp blood
either so I didn't have any any kind of
a clause now future things that we've
done since then especially things what
we do through nightfall we do have more
clauses in those type of agreements and
with whether it's you know the initial
production agreements or it's with
distributors you know with things like
that in terms of we we really go over
these contracts and really make sure we
can we look at every single right that
we're signing off on because all of
these rights matter and more now than
ever I would say and if there's a write
that they don't want what will retain it
and if there's a write that really we
really think we need to keep then we'll
argue for it and keep it you know that's
something frankly that Josephine is more
adept at than me you know we both look
at the contracts but she's she's in
favor of protecting me actually and and
trying to get us the best deals and the
best agreements and protect ourselves
too for like future you know sequels or
renewals you know you have sometimes
with you know relicensing this type of
stuff so we're you know it's always a
learning process everybody's always
learning and most filmmakers they make
bad deals and things like that in their
first films because they just want to
get the movie released and you know
right I guess because there's that
hunger and then this true that there's
people that will take your place if you
know yeah yeah and I've had I've had
that happen to me I mean I've had movies
that I I had one film for this same
producer where I I just basically I've
stepped off of it because I said you
know I it collapsed I won't get into the
details but it collapsed after I'd done
a ton of work on it and I said I said to
him you know what I can't rebuild this
whole movie again like in terms of
rescheduling reproducing almost the
whole movie and then he said okay fine
and then he went and just got somebody
else to direct it and you know it wasn't
anything great it wasn't anything
special it's not like something I wish I
had done that because that movie turned
out to be a huge hit and no not hardly
but that type of thing can happen to you
anytime even when these tiny films
people think that stuff happens on big
studio movie those people look well yeah
it does I mean it's people lurking
around it happens on low-budget films
all the time you know in fact it might
even have been more because there are
more people that are angling to get up
the ladder quicker
whereas on studio film like a paramount
film the grip is probably okay with
being a grid you know the the
you know the guy was doing craft
services he's probably cool with that
he's doing pretty well with that he's
probably alright with it he doesn't want
to direct the movie you know or any
movie whereas I feel like on these
smaller film so that's the downsides in
the club budget is everybody's kind of
like angling to bump up the ladder so
you know I've had you know effects
people want to direct and you know DP
wants to direct there's always you know
I'm not seeing that's on every set but
it does happen so you know and when it
happens to you it actually really
happens to you then you really become
aware of it you know yeah that's the
interesting part about the entertainment
industry that that's that angling I like
that yeah they are they're angling and
and I mean we even had on I mean you
know it happens on everything yeah in a
lot of scenarios and so I think it's
just being aware of that yeah and sort
of like okay I'm feeling that there's an
angling but I'm not sure what it is and
then just being ready yeah I'm
protective yeah but that was one of
those situation you mentioned early did
I speak up that I say what I thought oh
yeah I did because that was toward the
end of my working relationship with that
guy and I did tell him in no uncertain
terms I'm not scared rescheduling this
entire film and bringing all these
people and everything on you know we
cause they have they have schedules -
believe it or not they everybody has
schedules and that was not going to read
to the whole film just just because one
person didn't show up and then the whole
thing started following like a house of
cards
sometimes these movies are very fragile
things and they're fragile for us I mean
they're it's always scary you know
shooting especially on lower budget
things it's always scary - there's
always a bit of a terror involved
because you want everything needs to
come together right then and there for
it to really work so there's always a
lot of stress I don't care how many
movies you made you know the day before
or night before you don't get a lot of
sleep yeah that's true and then you have
to be up so early and then yeah you're
like a mess for that one day and then I
mean we were we were like like the last
thing like on high death we shot at
Bronson caves and you know that's all
outdoors obviously a whole day we're
going to be outdoors and you know
weather issues that's it you're not
going to shoot and we had everything
prepped so the night before literally
like 2:00 in the morning at 3:00 and
when we started hearing rain it was like
unfor cast rain coming down
like 3:00 a.m. 4:00 a.m. I'm like this
day is screwed but luckily by time we
actually got out there which is pretty
early in the morning still probably 6 or
7 a.m. it had stopped raining and it is
starting to dry off a little bit but you
know those type of things can drive you
nuts
I mean when you shoot outdoors weather
is like sometimes you can save a lot of
money by shooting outdoors but the
downside is if you have inclement
weather or other noise issues or things
that can really bite you you know
you